array is a relationship same idea as
comparison
but the important thing is that it's
between two connected
quantities two connected quantities
right
and here are a whole bunch of examples
you can see why they might use the word
um comparison
because you're comparing how much you
get of one thing with how much you get
of another
okay so we're going to do a couple of
things underneath this heading
of rage the first thing is we're going
to be converting some raids
okay so here's a little subheading
okay let's go with the first one because
um
speeds are something we're familiar with
we understand them intuitively
they're quite easy to work with let's
think about something like say
the speed limit on most of the roads
around here well not around here here
but once you get onto a decent sized
road
60 kilometers per hour is how fast you
can drive
right how fast you're supposed to drive
there's the comparison between the two
quantities there's a distance
and there's a time
and time usually is the second quantity
it usually is but as you can see it
doesn't have to be okay right
so we can convert this we can convert
this to something else
equivalent for example um i can write i
just write equals
instead of having kilometers per hour i
could very easily convert this into
kilometers
per minute kilometers per minute so all
i'm doing is i'm changing
one of the quantities over here and i'm
substituting it for something equivalent
okay so the column is still the same 60
kilometers but how many minutes are
there in an hour
and there are 60 right so i'm going to
say from this line to this line
instead of one hour that's one hour
isn't it i'm going to write 60 minutes
over the right hand side
okay now that's true but it's been an
awkward way to say it usually when we
have
these kinds of rates what we want is one
of these
on the end right this second quantity we
just want to know how much of the first
quantity you get
for one of these okay so what we want to
have is one minute over here on the
right hand side
right so what am i going to do to both
of these quantities to get one minute
divided by 60 excellent as you can see
it's a little bit like a fraction okay
and what we're doing is we're cancelling
we're simplifying down okay you've got a
common factor there
no problem as you'll see in a second
though they're not exactly the same
as fractions even though they're very
similar okay
let's do another one uh this time a
simple one um
i think the example that your textbook
gives you is is example two
if i count out the number of words that
someone can type per minute
okay you're following with that right so
for example i actually wonder what's a
decent sort of typing speed
but i'm gonna go for i think they say
something like 800 words
per what is it i don't know maybe let's
do let's do an awkward number
like seven minutes okay so here's the
idea suppose you get given
a um and there are there are online
things that will do this right they give
you a passage of um 800 words
okay and then you have to type it out
with accuracy and then we
press a timer on you and see how long it
takes you to finish the whole
passage right okay so if i want just
like i have here
and here if i want the second quantity
for this to be
one of them and that'll give me a
comparison between these two again
what do i have to do to both quantities
to get this in terms of just one minute
all you have to do is divide by seven
right so you're going to get 800 on
seven words however many that is okay
per
minute okay so you've canceled that's a
bit of an awkward way to say it so maybe
if you have your calculator there
you want to go ahead and calculate this
and get an approximation
maybe we'll do one decimal place i think
that would be enough to give you the
idea
114.3.3
okay there you go no problem now let me
push on this a little bit because i said
that what we've been doing so far very
very similar to fractions
but there's some differences okay um for
instance let's think about um
let's go a bit faster let's go
interstate okay so this is example three
i'll stay with speed because we're quite
good at understanding this
kilos per hour is the is the national
sort of speed limit so if you're on a
big highway
that's as fast as you can go okay but
you can do something to rates that you
can't do to fractions
which is to say 110 kilometers per hour
is really the same as saying one hour
for 110 kilometers these rates are
actually the same
okay because they're still comparing the
same two quantities it doesn't matter
which way you say it okay
you can't do that with fractions though
can you you know 3 over 4
is not the same as 4 over 3 right
because
a fraction is not exactly a relationship
between two connected quantities
it's numbers and this could mean a whole
variety of things right but being that
we're thinking specifically about rates
we can do this okay so
just like before okay i want to think
about you know this is 100 kilometers
per hour and there's one of these over
here so now i want to do the same thing
but
well how many hours does it take to go
one kilometer
that's not an unusual slow question okay
so what am i going to do just like
before
i want one kilometer on the right hand
side i'll divide by 110 okay so here we
go
you do this
okay now that's true it's it's somewhat
of an awkward way to say it though
okay um so just like before this
fraction isn't all that helpful
right we could express this as a decimal
but something that might be even more
helpful here is converting
like we did over here between different
units okay
so instead of hours what should we put
in here we could choose
minutes or we could choose seconds which
do you think just
on instinct which do you think might be
a more helpful
unit to choose i think probably seconds
okay as you'll see why uh
in a second y seconds is a more natural
choice
how we're going to do this now because
it's a time you have an advantage to
this which is on your calculator you
actually have
um just to the right of that negative
button
in the middle of these grey buttons
you've got a button that looks like this
does anyone know what it's called it's
the degrees
minutes seconds button in fact on some
calculators
it actually just says degrees minutes
seconds okay
now if you do your 1 divided by 110 okay
you do that
and at least on my calculator it just
spits back a fraction right
but if you hit your hours minutes
seconds or degrees minutes seconds
button right like that here's what you
get this is what my calculator says
anyway
it says after i press this i see this
okay now degrees minutes seconds
degrees are divided up in exactly the
same way that
hours are divided up namely there are 60
minutes in a degree
and 60 seconds in a minute just the same
as time
okay so therefore how do you read this
what did these three numbers
signify it's there's the hours
right there's the minutes and sorry
i know how it works and there's the
seconds okay
so there you go um 32.73 let's just do
0.7
does that sound about right it sounds
about right i think it does
you know um we looked before and we saw
okay you'll go
one kilometer in a minute over here um
this is
less than a minute it's just a bit over
half well that's because we're traveling
or
about twice as fast well a little less
you get the idea
you can see why that's a better choice
than minutes can't you because this is
still less than a minute
right and you can sort of estimate that
from here um sorry from here but if
you've gotten that wrong the first time
if you've done minutes in here
i'm guessing from that it'd be something
like 0.5
something and you say oh okay maybe i
should convert to a more helpful unit
okay now for what it's worth you won't
usually have to
actually pick which unit if you have a
look at exercise 2g with me
they overwhelmingly provide for you the
units that you want
all you have to keep in mind is number
one dividing by the right numbers
and number two knowing how to convert
between different
units of the same kind of quantity like
hours minutes seconds or
kilograms and grams and all those kinds
of things okay